in five four three two one
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast we
got the very very special guests they're
gonna introduce themselves again what a
mansion boy Chris Sosa it's your boy
bhakti Duran do you think it's right off
the bat do you think Chris is a hard
worker Oh get dancing and nitty gritty I
think I think he can be a hard worker if
he's if he's given a certain push or if
it's something that he actually likes to
do yeah absolutely that's a good answer
that's the truth I concur yeah yeah I I
agree
I um I ended up putting myself I have
this thing about myself that like Oh
since I was younger I didn't like doing
things with groups I like doing [ __ ]
myself
I liked you know I know how I see it and
I know that I would kill it like even
like projects in school like [ __ ] group
projects yeah man and because I wanted
to do it myself and I wanted it to be
badass and I like the the attention that
I got of like yo you did that I'm like
yeah I did that you know like I was like
I just I was just like that was my ego
man is just wanted to do [ __ ] myself and
even when like when I made the decision
and like start making sketches and [ __ ]
on YouTube like I started making
sketches back when nigahiga first came
out Timothy DeLaGhetto like I was a fan
of Tim Adela girl we do those kids
before I was fam oh six oh seven
oh that's before me doing sketches man
with my brother
that we're the oh geez like but and then
even with uh with JK films bro I was
watching Joe and Bart make these
sketches I have a there's a sketch that
they made that was um they had like a
dojo and they were like training you
talking about daniel and samuel yes sir
and that one inspired me to make my my
dojo master salsa whatever
sketch of like um you know trying to
teach discipline or all these things and
because of them I just got a little I
got discouraged because I was watching
Tim Tims like content and JK films like
their content started getting better
video quality
they had mics like when I saw there was
a guy that had a boom one time there was
like an outtake whatever but they showed
I saw that they had a guy with unsound
and I was like I'm dying yeah because I
just had all I had was it was a camera
that was like just a straight-up digital
camera but I had a video feature on it
like a Sony little digital camera that
was like you know at the back then it
was like what uh nine megapixels like it
was like oh yeah yeah yeah and so I
would use that to make my sketches and
then I had a tripod that was my biggest
like production thing I had a tripod so
I can click record and wander further my
camera yeah and so in that crazy though
how back in the day when YouTube was
starting and it was going to that
transition it was about high quality
[ __ ]
but now the worst quality [ __ ] does the
best it's just like on the front end of
your camera and that's the content that
there's way better than high production
quality [ __ ] nobody wants to see that
[ __ ] easy any did I should [ __ ] what
yeah man and and and like even like like
came onstage for instance like he not
saying his consciousness conscious no
his career is great but his video
quality is trash will get because though
because he says he is actually like
determined to show people that he has
made his whole career [ __ ]
I like often his phone office was
amazing and and he is committed to it he
makes content every day he floods
content and his podcast record on the
phone his his split screen quarter on
the phone you know everything off of his
phone all the thing he did was buy
another phone yes I can have two angles
or multiple angles but and then and then
you know he has this guy or you know the
homie Joshy guns to where the premium
content that gets the the great you know
on stop working like I it's funny
because when he came on to my podcast
like I got put on to him by Tim and as I
go this guy's [ __ ] funny man no
being himself like I'm really good at
this [ __ ] yeah and he came out that
means like he's like your mom big fan of
me I was like what do you mean like he
was telling me that when he used to work
in a bank used to watch my [ __ ] all the
time and then he got sad when I switched
over to a podcast because I stopped
doing the the the videos my vlogs were I
talking to a camera it's like maybe you
just like every one of my fans you
[ __ ] I was like oh [ __ ] like I
didn't realize that you know cuz you
don't realize the ripple effect that you
have on other people yeah right because
somebody who liked my content I'm
arguably a bigger if maybe a bigger fan
of him and he is probably of me
yeah hate and I'm like you know I love
watching keV stuff all the time am I
know this dude's [ __ ] funny now he's
doing stand-up shows he's like on his
Kevin Hart route not on a smaller scale
but he has that same Kevin Hart hustle
it's color it's not about perfecting
your craft per se in that type of sense
but it's about perfecting your craft but
he doesn't hold things precious to him
he goes if I don't if I stop working I
stop putting stuff out people gonna
forget me
yeah which is true that's what happens
right and I admire that [ __ ] so much
because he understands that everything
that he puts out it's not gonna be a
masterpiece yeah but nobody's expecting
that out of them right they just want to
laugh and they just want to hear what he
has to say yeah which is pretty awesome
yeah man I think that's like so dope
about him man he has that call in in and
then like even going to him about like
advisor because he's the homie man you
can call him if he's free cuz the man's
always you know we're doing something
but he'll always chop it over me but the
moment I find myself same thing with
Bochy too but the moment I find myself
giving an excuse
talking to keV I'm glad I'm like yo cuz
I'd be like I know but it's just like
whenever I go home and I you know I
don't have the time and I cut myself off
cuz I'm like keV has a straight-up
family got a family has a whole family
and he's a straight-up family man yet
yeah bro like going to all the soccer
games going up taking them to school but
he just found a way to manage his time
to where I remember when we're at all
deaf we would literally we were watching
his schedule he would on his way home I
mean on the way to work you drop the
kids off on the way he's like like a
our something commute right going all
the way from the firm Reseda all the way
down to downtown
he's on live he puts his phone on the on
the windshield and he's on like a
periscope talking to those fans
he has his 95 crew which is now the
stage crew shout out to them but he's
building that engagement comes to work
at all dev so it's like a [ __ ]
playground you're creating content all
over the place at all dev goes home on
the way home gets back on life because
live again goes home makes a piece of
content does a split screen and then
family time there's the same [ __ ] again
I can't live like that and he was doing
that for like three years bro straight I
was like breath so there's like no
excuse I can't like I can't come up with
[ __ ] to talk when I'm talking to keV fo
makes me feel guilty for jacking off
it's like damn I took the time to touch
my dick and keV would not do this yeah
you know what keV we'll be doing keV
would figure out a way to turn that into
a sex tape and sell it that's what yeah
keV on dick stage or some [ __ ] dude keV
is that dope he is that [ __ ] guy man
anyone just Kevin Hart [ __ ] he's like
dude I don't work hard enough that's
funny cuz I look at your sometimes I
don't work hard enough care which is
insane he's like the nicest dude ever
man I feel like a piece of [ __ ] around
him yeah I went to church the next day
because of him dude oh man he's a great
bright and we moved out here the same
time he he moved out here a month before
I did that's crazy and I'm and and I
moved in it you know month later
whatever and we met on Easter Ray's um
she had a she was she was producing and
directing a web series called the choir
and that's how we met cuz he was like
the um you know in churches they have
the dancers yeah yeah so he was the the
you know the Prince the the the the
master dancer right and then I was one
of the products like the prodigy so I
was always right under him but I was
like the teacher's pet to him and that's
how we met I remember asking him about
advice on how to do stand-up cuz he did
stand-up comedy I was like bro Oh like
how do you like go abroad like riding a
joke and always things like started from
then and then now this guy's on his
third tour bro that's crazy and he kind
of developed his own tour he didn't wait
for somebody to put him on that's what
it's like inspired me I said I put up in
the universe man I want to do a low-key
tour bro what the [ __ ] are you do I
never see you post it alright buddy you
know
guy right here I'm so sick of your [ __ ]
you lazy little [ __ ]
and would you two go home and beat your
own ass that's what you need to do there
nobody got time to be jazz for you you
little [ __ ] how are you gonna have that
six tour show well it takes the six City
show if you can't do that
it's a photo man see I like I like
negative reinforcements what I grew some
people don't but it works for me though
if somebody's like yo man you [ __ ]
lazy piece of [ __ ] on my own I am lazy
I found it doesn't work for my brother
because I started talking to him like
that yeah and NAFA went to a spiraling
depression yeah yeah man no that's true
bro like I couldn't that's the thing I
really don't like giving excuses so it's
really like I own up to the [ __ ] I mean
obviously from the [ __ ] that I've told
y'all and y'all [ __ ] rose before as
though I'm never gonna give anybody that
of like me all you do is [ __ ] give
excuses now man I'm not doing the way I
should be doing you know I mean it's
always hard though I think like keV is
also a very unique human being
specifically because I truly believe
when I see keV
number one hardest [ __ ] working dude
I've ever met in my life personally that
I got to know in that type of sense but
also - he's like he's he's half artist
half business right and I think also his
motivation in life is different from us
he has a kid in a family right so for us
and specifically you you're super young
so it's it's really hard because you
don't really have that crazy monkey on
your back and the level of success that
you've had up to this point it's pretty
[ __ ] amazing now it's like the hard
part is when you have a life that you've
always wanted and it's here it's like
well how do I create more when I'm
comfortable because when you're about to
be broke and you have no money in your
[ __ ] pocket yeah a different hustle
when you have kids a family and you have
you know three people at home that are
waiting to make sure they didn't bring
home a paycheck so we could live the
life that we want to live it's a
different type of hustle yeah you know
so that's where that that motivation
starts to disappear I like I'm still
trying to find that motivation again
like the way the amount that I used to
work before - how I am now it's a it's
it's a different game right so the the
way I used to work before was constant
it was consistent but at the same time
for me I didn't have any doors open well
now doors are open for me
so now it's a matter of pouncing work
and then me being happy right right now
mind you if I had a kid my happiness is
probably in that kid so all the work
that I'll take give me whatever I'm
ready right now because I have options
and now I'm trying to figure out what
I'm happy and what I'm passionate about
right that's where it becomes difficult
for you if you want to be a major
stand-up comic and that's where you want
to go then you have you have your wife
or your life now it's just all about
your how why is Chris so so wants to be
on the on the top tier level of stand-up
comics in this world well your Y is
already there which is the hardest part
for most people to find out most people
don't know that Y if I ask somebody a
site what's your goal in life is like
well like I would like to be happy
cool that's not a y what's your goal in
life what's your why what's your why you
already have your Y so it literally 70%
of the work is done now the other 30% is
the whole part yeah this podcast is
brought to you by skill share my friends
if you don't know what skill share is I
wonder if you are tackling your new
year's goal to be a better you well
guess what let me tell you what skill
sharing of skill share is an online
learning community that offers
membership with meaning with so much to
explore real projects to create and the
support of fellow creative skill share
empowers you to in kampala sh real
growth skill share is also incredibly
affordable especially when compared to
pricy in-person classes and workshops an
annual subscription is less than $10 a
month I have been using Skillshare to
sharpen up my photography and
videography skills because you know I
use that on the daily and I'd like to
learn at my own pace so a lot of
traditional learning you don't have that
you have to learn when somebody tells
you to learn they give you all these
tests well some of us like to learn in
our own spare time and when we have a
busy life we want to be able to pick and
choose when we can do it and Skillshare
with their huge database of knowledge
has got your back baby
so Skillshare is a proud sponsor of
genius brain explore your creativity and
skill share comm slash brain and get to
three months of premium membership
that's two whole months of unlimited
access to thousands of classes for free
get started and joined today by heading
to Skillshare comm slash brain that
Skillshare comm slash brain so if
you--if you now your time should be
spent on your how how am I going
get there is it do I need more
visibility do I have to collab more do I
have to hit more comedy clubs should I
be making more sketches should I be
doing this and that's where you really
have to find your functioning purpose
and the reason why it's important for
people to have a why because every no
matter what you do everything goes back
to your why every move that you make you
go what's my wife yeah if it's not if
it's not [ __ ] with my wife I'm gonna
drop this [ __ ] right so that's probably
can probably help you get to your
motivation if you know what that Y is
you write it down and you start making a
movie site is it for my wife yeah yeah
you know oh yeah bro and I actually like
just you know being now that I am like
by myself because this is my first time
living by myself since I've been in LA
so this is another like transition of
like I'm by myself now I have like I
really all I have is my reflection it's
just like it's just me and you bro you
know I'm saying it's like we got to
figure this [ __ ] out like what are we
gonna cuz you know living with body but
it would it would be like that like
let's make a sketch real quick or he was
writing that night or something yeah
we'd be writing something we bought a
whole case of redbull one time bro on
some dumb [ __ ] we just went to went to
the grocery store to get a Red Bull each
but then you know they had like the
display of like all the red Red Bulls
and we're just like on the box that said
you could buy the whole case for like 25
bucks or some [ __ ] yes some dumb [ __ ]
and we're like [ __ ] it again I like
that's how I am but I just have a
[ __ ] thing where I was like all right
let's go let's do this [ __ ] and we just
started like you know creating and doing
that thing but again I had somebody
there to be like alright let's do it on
my own by myself you know I got my
personal life that that's also something
I'm going through and you know getting
through that [ __ ] and also living on my
own so I'm like now I got a do regular
life [ __ ] I got a like you know washing
dishes doing laundry doing this cleaning
up you know take my dog out I still got
clipped my dog's nails my poor little
doggies nails is like curling under the
falls I'm like I gotta get my [ __ ]
together you know I'm saying even my
dogs just like bruh what you gonna do
look at now help me yeah [ __ ] yeah you
know I'm saying it's
you know I it's like just getting all
that [ __ ] together and then 2020 bro
like the fact that like it started off
like you know everybody has a New Year's
resolution but then it's the fact that
it's a whole new decade it's 2020 it's
had it's added a whole new extra like
umph to it you know and it was just like
okay cool and then I got into a position
now where it's like I got a straight up
job and I was like damn like kind of
like messed with my motivation you know
say cuz that now I'm like on a whole
full-time thing instead of like I wanted
to push and just do just me I can't I
got to go clock in I got to spend you
know me but then that there goes a whole
[ __ ] Gary Vee thing where it's like
who gives a [ __ ] when you get off we're
doing with the other six 12 hours of
your day whatever you know I mean I'm
like Jesus Christ Gary give me a break
yeah and then you know it's it's always
going to be overwhelming you know I'm
saying no matter what you do it's just
like at the end of the day because I
holiday you right now 26 yeah you 26 I
was 26 when I first came here right so
when I first came here I was 26 maybe 25
yeah roughly around there
yeah maybe 25 something like a year when
you came in when you were 25 24 I came
when I moved out here yeah I moved out
here when I was uh nineteen nineteen
okay while I was here I can move your
nose like 25 I say around there right I
had I think a hundred and fifty bucks in
my bank account sold everything that I
owned every Dornan shoe that I wanted
whatever I sold all that [ __ ] you know I
had a DSLR camera that I saved up and
then my dad has his peace offering for
to me he bought me an iMac so I can edit
my [ __ ] no so he was like fine if this
is what you're gonna commit to do you're
gonna to go and do it yeah my first year
when I came to LA my very first paycheck
on YouTube I I'm I might even be over
exaggerating how much money this was I
think it was $400 my rent was 200 bucks
because my my cousin allowed me to live
it at the place and he only allowed me
to pay 200 to 250 bucks a month for that
room oh my so he helped me out so I had
to do that the things that I ate
everyday was [ __ ] unless he took me
out to eat
it was [ __ ] ramen I
rice eggs that's all I [ __ ] ate yeah
and this is during the time that I was
doing those vlogs like in my room by
myself and I wasn't making any money
there was no money to be made at the
time so every every time that I spent in
him we were just talking about this the
other day about the progression of where
I started till now I would be in the
room and I would write I would scope
through all my old stand-up to try to
reconvert it into these vlogs and I
would write every [ __ ] week and I
didn't not post on Sunday for I think
like six years straight every day non
[ __ ] stop if I had extra ideas I put
it in there I was writing sketches and I
was trying to do things all the [ __ ]
time and you know the motivation was
very different at that point but I
remember at that point feeling like if I
don't post on a Sunday my life is over
mm-hmm you know what I mean and so if
you're already at a point right now
you're 26 which is hyper young
specifically entertainment that's super
[ __ ] young and you're you're having
trouble finding the motivation I said
I'll only get harder when you actually
really do find success right when you
find success and you're there and you're
at the end point and you're actually
beyond I'm actually beyond where I
thought I was gonna be at this age right
people I you know I say this before as a
joke but is real like I didn't even
think I was gonna live till I was 30 I
doesn't be dead by now so anything else
here is a cherry on top for me yeah so
now I need to figure out what's my
motivation to keep me going you're 26
right now yeah you you're not even at
your 30s yet and 30s is still super
[ __ ] young like I'm 31 right now yeah
super [ __ ] young so it's like for you
I think the whole what I always like to
tell people is like one of the most
things that I'm scared of I think this
is like my true fear you know [ __ ] being
scared of heights of spiders or whatever
I'm scared that one day when I'm about
to die I'm gonna look up and said [ __ ] I
wish I could have done more that's like
my biggest [ __ ] fear because I can't
do anything at that point yeah like I
look back and I go oh [ __ ] if when I was
in my when I was 26 and those times that
I was thinking about I'm not motivated I
can't do this stuff I wish I would have
done this instead and so that's how I
try to live my life right now yeah I
can't live with regrets that's why I did
the film that's why I tried doing
stand-up
that's why I tried doing sketches I did
all this random [ __ ] that's why I opened
up these food businesses because it's
like this is something I want to do I'm
gonna [ __ ] do it
whether I fail or not at least I could
say I tried yeah even with acting I did
it for a whole year right and now it's
like it wasn't really hyper passionate
about it I'm still acting now but I did
it because not because I am a thespian
who wants to [ __ ] act is because I
said to myself you don't know when
you're on that deathbed if you're gonna
say oh [ __ ] I wish I could have acted
yeah
so I did it so I checked it off and now
I can move on for him or I could still
do it and it's really up to me yeah so
right now if you're finding out
motivation for yourself I don't know how
you function if you function like I do
but you have opportunities right now
it's all there yeah you know so do you
want to look back and say like [ __ ] keV
told me this David told me this I had
all these opportunities but the only
thing that stopped me was [ __ ] my life
is too hectic everybody's life is hectic
bro right yeah yeah I mean everybody's
life is hectic I've seen people I've
seen people in college when I was in
college there was a lady when I was at
CRC was a community college in
Sacramento there was a lady who was a
registered nurse she wanted to switch
careers but on her off day she set up
her classes she had five [ __ ] kids no
husband five kids registered nurse had
to go to school and she aced every one
of her [ __ ] classes jeez
so you know what I mean like we got
excuses other people have living
situations where they have to so we're
kind of put into our search it's
something you're complaining but I got a
full-time job
I got benefits man well the thing is is
like it's also my thing of like I like
to be able to create at all times and I
feel like something that's hold when
something's holding me back then I start
feeling like Wolfe [ __ ] it like I saw I
like not really like not look like a
[ __ ] but like it's like damn I wish I
I wish I could be just doing something
else instead of being held in to this
list like this box I wish I could be
like creating right now I like being
like how like we had this idea for a
sketch let's go shoot the [ __ ] you know
what I mean I just need one person to be
on camera
we could do a sound we could finesse the
sound like whatever the case was it was
like boom I want to create this [ __ ]
but you know do it and I mind you the
job that I have is like a [ __ ]
blessing it's like it's like yeah it is
but it is just it's thinking about my
why you know it's like a it's like a can
its it's still industry it can it
definitely is an industry job that does
the with as far as relationships go yes
it does help but at the end of the day I
just always see my why and I'm always
looking at it just like I have to be
able to in order to get to that next
tier I see it as like a pyramid and I'm
like I'm like I'd like you know maybe
third to the top but it's like hella
comfortable you know me money's nice
relationships everybody's cool like I
can actually live here and chill you
know I mean but it's like I'm just gonna
forever be looking at the top yeah it's
like damn that would be nice you know I
mean and like I'll never know how what
that's like and to I mean that stuff to
really think about like obviously
there's there's a point where you have
to have your bases covered right because
a job pays your [ __ ] rent you steady
income right and it's has something that
you need and you also enjoy it and it
feels like a blessing then continue to
do it but you know there's so many
towers out in the day yo [ __ ] you
[ __ ] not this is not me trying to
flex on people about how hard I worked
or whatever is because I always had
clinical insomnia I slept in average to
2 to 3 hours a day up until about a
couple years ago really every night to 3
hours that's all I was leaving and
losing my [ __ ] mind I'm actually 13
years old I I couldn't go to sleep so
like on those off times like people
always say it's like yo how do you know
all this random [ __ ] it's an insomniac
all I could do is stay up and reach it
know all the [ __ ] time that's why
when I came on this Food Show they're
like why do you know so much about food
I was an insomniac and I love food so I
just read about cuisine all the [ __ ]
time that's all I would do yeah so even
none of those times just like I know
that it's I don't suggest people in
sleep 3 hour to try to learn and you
know hone your craft but there is a lot
of hours out in the day it's just really
about how we utilize right
sometimes when people say like amen I
don't really have time for my friends or
whatever what not not that you don't
have time for your friends you choose
not to make time for people you don't
really give that much of a [ __ ] about
it's what it is right yeah because if
you if it was your boy boy he comes in -
he comes in to town he goes yo I'm a
beautiful five days cool dropping
everything we kickin it for five days
right right right
so it's the same thing with text
messages or same thing with everything
else and you put it in that perspective
and then you had that type of mentality
for your work it's like do I really am I
really that busy or am I just not
motivated enough to really put the time
in to work on this right now and it's
hard an art art is very hard to stay
motivated specifically when you're by
yourself because everything is generated
from you and when you're not inspired
you're not living the life that you want
sometimes your art doesn't come out very
difficult man I have so much art like
actual paintings that are not finished
because I get hella motivator to get on
it and I'm like I'm doing like this this
one there's one piece that I'm working
on man it's that's like it's one of my
best ones I did it but I get to a point
where like it's like I'm working on it
way too long you can hear I'm kind of
like if like I had a little [ __ ] oh my
all right let me let me step away from
it you know I mean and then I just never
get back to it I don't I don't feel like
the that motivation again of like how I
felt when I when I first started you
know me and I know that it should be
like okay well instead of trying to
finish the whole thing and think about
the end goal just you know work on it
for an hour paint for an hour and then
let it go and then just do that hour by
hour you know everyday whatever and then
you'll finish the [ __ ] painting but
it's just like I have a whole portfolio
like you know big ass folder of just
unfinished paintings that I was gonna
think about a hole I was actually gonna
have a whole exhibit called unfinished
paintings and just show you know that
[ __ ] you know I mean finish it and you
paint - yeah bro man that's what I'm
saying man I do a lot of [ __ ] it's just
it's just trying to figure out which one
I should put more attention to because I
do a lot bro
I like it you can't you can't be a jack
of all shits though like that was the
hardest thing that I had to learn
because when I first started doing
YouTube so I used to have a music
channel before the one I had now I don't
even use is dead now prior to me doing
David so comedy I actually had a music
channel it was called like acoustic soul
right that at the time for YouTube it
had like 200,000 subscribers that was
like having like three million followers
now yeah
equivalent oh for sure I chose that I
had a point where I was like listen you
can't be a musician and do comedy at the
same time you could come back and tackle
music after you feel like you
accomplished one I thought I deleted
that channel I 200,000 followers on that
I deleted it and then I started David so
comedy because I had to make a choice I
was like you can you can be mediocre at
five different things or you can be
great at one thing so I deleted that
channel yeah
that shows [ __ ] hard yeah I was like
hovering over you know just not being
able to do it for the longest time that
channel I completely deleted and I took
away all the content because I said like
I you if you keep you keep you dip your
hands in too many things it's what I do
right now but I had the luxury to be
able to do this right now not when I was
younger when I first started off because
my time would be split in two trying to
master two or three different crafts I
would I wouldn't be getting anywhere
I'll be swimming in circles yeah so if
that's your problem right now when
you're when your foot is barely in the
door you really do have to focus on one
thing that's my advice maybe people can
do other things but Jamie Foxx had the
same thing right yeah he had a tackle
one thing he needed the music after
because he really wanted to do music
yeah and then it was the it was the
comedy that catapulted him to be able to
be in a position of like alright imma
throw parties and what no he had his own
studio in his crib and when Kanye was
there jay-z and then were there Kanye
had a song for him ready boom knocked it
out you know I mean I've heard just
Jamie's story so many times but I loved
it though but it's like that's what he
said though he's like I ended up doing
music way after because he he was like I
couldn't be doing Wanda and and in and
then they tried to take me serious as a
singer he wanted to be a you know a sex
symbol R&B singer yeah
but it was like no your Wanda you know
say so you know yeah I try to I try to
um you know I think about that all the
time am i doing am i doing too much and
like you said being mediocre and all
these things so it's like which one do I
pick you know at the comedy so far stand
up so stand up is like my main one that
I feel in control about because then
acting it's a waiting game or it's like
it's not even personal well let me ask
you this then where do you feel alive
the most right cuz I I don't really
pursue stand up anymore because after I
did a couple of shows not too long ago
killed the set people were dying
laughing I walked out feeling empty I
was like this doesn't matter
mmm doesn't matter if I kill the set or
not doesn't feel that great yeah I think
I'm an amazing stand-up comic but I did
really well that night and only I don't
care mm-hm
I was like oh [ __ ] and it's not for me
as of right now and I'll come back later
when I'm a little older or something
like that but I'm 31 I'm like I don't
really care about doing this right now
yeah I'm doing a couple shows I'm doing
one in Jersey and I'm doing one in New
York just to kind of try it again to see
if I feel that same way but I already
know that I have a feeling that it it
might go well and if it does I'm
probably gonna feel the same way imma be
like I killed it cool whatever move on
well you're gonna end up having like a
dope-ass [ __ ] special bro house and
the thing is gonna be like the comedy
special that's like you know hella
intimate you know saying you're gonna
talk this [ __ ] that you really want to
talk you're not gonna get I already I
already see it bro you're not gonna have
any limits you're gonna talk that [ __ ]
that you really want to talk and it's
gonna be no boundaries and it's gonna be
a [ __ ] classic that's why I like this
podcast cuz I get to just say whatever
the [ __ ] I want you know like when I was
doing like JK news is not that platform
their fans are not made for that they
don't want to hear whatever the [ __ ] we
say yeah they want us to say what they
want to hear so like JK news fans or
some other [ __ ] you know I mean so when
I left that space and I came here I was
like oh I'm back on my [ __ ] my fans are
different they say what are the [ __ ] I
want and they'll understand what I say
even though it's severe it's clearly a
joke yeah yeah I mean like I'm trying to
finesse it in a way where it's a joke
and even on sometimes with JK news
they're finessing it as a joke they just
don't hear it
so you know it's a joke it was finessed
that way like it was set up perfectly
most people get it but you know there's
just people they just want to be
negative as [ __ ] but you know what we'll
see is like if you if you do stand-up
but every time you kill a set you feel
like you feel alive that might be your
[ __ ] right because I don't I don't
really feel that way about stand-up no
no no what I feel that way about it for
food right now so that's why I'm
tackling food really hard right now
that's something that makes me happy
when right people walk away they drink
the drink they eat the food and they
feel that makes me feel good I'm like oh
this is where my tips can go right now
mm-hmm
you know these things evolve all the
time too we never know what it's gonna
be now what ten years everybody changes
yeah but for you if comedy is your thing
and that should wide then you should be
sticking to that recipe you can't paint
mmm doesn't mean you can't do anything
whatever you're doing right but that
should be an ancillary thing like it
should be like oh I I do that one out
when I want yeah but you should be
focused on that one thing really well
and that's something that a lot of young
people have a problem with yeah because
we're in a it's luxury we have someone's
access matter exactly it's it's a
problem of luxury right that's why a lot
of old people say they go back in my day
we didn't talk about that [ __ ] it's like
yeah cuz you don't have options
[ __ ] yeah yeah like you were you
were still cooking with wood [ __ ] you
know fire turns on you open when fire
came on you're like the devil was alive
right different yeah yeah so because of
like wealth that we have options create
luxury luxury honestly gives us way too
much options it goes back and forth and
now we're thinking like I could do this
I could do that
I could do this yeah and it just kind of
[ __ ] people up makes people feel really
lost and it's not even so much that
you're lost is that you're just you're
trying to be too many things at once
you're not lost don't do this so right I
was a mute Minister for two years yes
right what would be like the kind of
argument like if it's like it just takes
that much longer to get to the same
point you're trying to get to that's
well the the the argument is is that
you're never gonna get to that point
because you're trying to be too many
people at once you just won't you know
you might be that dude that's people
will be like god you were so talented
and that's where the conversation is
yeah and I say that because I've seen
too many pee
we'll do that around me they go you were
so talented and the key word is work
because they try so hard to be so many
different [ __ ] things they spread
themselves way too thin they got caught
up on some [ __ ] they they never
focused into something that they truly
loved and they wanted her and they're
gonna be in that position where I'm
scared where I look back and I go [ __ ] I
wish I could have done more and I have a
couple of friends like that there's a
dude that I know that started to stand
up around the same time that I did
mm-hmm
now I bomb a thousand sets too but he
bombed as well and he just never picked
up his pieces after that mmm right and
even now he looks back and he goes man I
wish I was doing what you're doing
nobody said you couldn't like you just
you just wanted to do that you wanted to
do photography you wanted to do all this
other stuff and you never stuck to it
and I are arguably think that he's one
of the funniest guys I've ever met
hands down yeah he just never worked on
his craft he never he never [ __ ]
strapped up his boots and went through
having terrible sets went through a lot
of [ __ ] and he just thought that his
success was either gonna be instant or
he went for the instant gratitude and
trying different things because it feels
nice when somebody goes oh you're
talented at painting oh yeah you're also
really funny amen you ain't grace
catches oh you're pretty cool right oh
you work for this guy and those little
small things start to feel good and it
kind of skews your vision you like maybe
I should do this mmm no but this maybe I
should that's the that's the bar about
you said uh the worst thing you could
tell somebody is good job you can
testify is good job and it's true man
like that that's another thing too like
with like with working out basically I
would tell buck or anybody like my close
circle like I'm not gonna post a picture
of progress I'm not gonna post a picture
of like if I if my abs are coming in and
put because once I post it done done and
I go back to like like that was it like
I'd like okay here I go
ABS y'all you're welcome enjoy that and
then and then I go back to just chilling
yeah well you know they saw they saw
what it look like you know I mean they
saw the V it's all the V so I'm in the
gym I just look at buff people I go I
take their headphones off I go go home
you're gonna go home what are you doing
here
go away right right for real man I can't
I can't promote you know I
I'll record the footage now and I'll
have the content but I can't promote me
working now because it's for me it's
gonna make me stop because it's gonna
make me feel like alright I showed them
that I'm working now so that's good
enough you know I mean I still gonna
look progress my good enough I think you
just fall into the trap of just being a
talent to do like you also box
you had like 60 amateur boxing matches
like it's it's you just have so many
things you do well and I think the
that's like a blessing and a problem yes
like gives it a curse you got that Midas
Touch it's like yo I bet you if I tried
that [ __ ] eventually I'll get good at it
I really I get that'sthat's really he
said that plays us I have that thing of
like I can do that and it'll be good and
everybody's gonna [ __ ] with mine because
of I know I and that's just out like
you're right I it's just been that way
it's not even about a flex it's just I I
know what things work and how creatively
though common sense
I [ __ ] that a regular life [ __ ] yeah
I told my homeboy this one time and this
was like a deep car think about it was
there I'd like a deep combo with my
homie I was like bro like I I get
everything you know I'm very like
artistic and like as far as like I you
know creatively I get down like creative
sketches of painting dancing acting
stand-up comedy like bro I got that
regular [ __ ] a regular everyday life
common sense I don't have that [ __ ]
flipping your dogs tech nails you [ __ ]
he told me straight up he was like hey
bro that's called autism like bro I
really opened up my art that's all to
the bro you got that that's not even a
joke man
is that Rain Man [ __ ] bro you know you
know you don't got all the all the the
bolts tighten you know he told me he's
like my nephew's autistic bro you got
that [ __ ] like okay yeah man so I'll
just like you know I don't know but I
definitely consider that man for sure
it's like it's it's it's that it's it's
it's the people who are really talented
but then they get out worked
yeah and I've seen that and I'm actually
and all the time
I'm admitting it right now I think and
this is something I felt there are
stand-up comedians that I started with
that are definitely out out standing up
they're out working me yeah sure and I'm
being honest about it because it's like
I see it I see that they were on you
know this comedy show or this comment or
like prestige stages like the laugh
factor notice things like it why because
they stuck with stand-up show thing and
they and they put the work in and like
you said I just choose to do like
whatever I'm feeling at that time like I
feel like recording a song alright cool
who I know who does music okay who do I
know how this dude okay cool put me in
the booth and I just like start
recording a song and then I get into
this thing of like all problems start
come on do a little mixtape and I get
into this whole little thing then
botties he just tossed me this that
today because I had this idea and you
and he was like I'll be honest with you
bro I'm not [ __ ] with it until you
post a picture on our podcast I'm not
gonna go there with you yeah like there
what you own the idea I get that I like
I would back you up for that but it's
like you gotta get to the point where I
can trust you that you're gonna be able
to go through with what you're investing
in yeah you know yeah feels like an
intervention guys tell you about it but
yeah yeah actually about the music in
you bout the Chris real quick put him on
the podcast real quick to me that it's
really impressive man guys I'm not about
to put bought day on the spot man
because me I like when it's since he's
been here man he actually is probably
cuz he went to college appreciate you
cut up but uh which by the way you
finish that thesis until you finish yeah
until you finish
that thesis how long you've been working
on this thank you three years okay cool
so I'll post a picture when you finish
it these so um so but but this guy's
worked at McMahon for real like he
actually like he actually gets [ __ ] done
which sounds super simple but like what
he says he's gonna do he gets it gets it
done he shows up for the podcast and
everything he's always [ __ ] pulling
up and I'm like damn that work ethic is
something that I'm like I'm still
finding you know I'm saying like oh that
type of working I always go I'll get it
done and when I do it'll be nice I'm
always like that instead of just getting
the [ __ ] done yeah do it I'm only saying
this to you because I have your exact
same habits right so it's like I get it
done but how much more officially I
could could I have done this without
wasting my time wasting other people's
time yeah I could have done this like
it's it's there please please listen you
know like the other day too I sat down
and I was like I'm gonna rebrand myself
not in terms of rebrand myself but kind
of put into exact words it's the same
advice that I gave all my business
partners when we were working and
branding like the macho stuff is stuff
and I was like how come I'm gonna taking
my own advice like you know why don't
you do this you're gonna sit down and
knock it out I wrote three words on
Google duck and then I started watching
don't don't [ __ ] with cats then I watch
the Aaron [ __ ] Hernandez whatever
[ __ ] documentary that's like what the
[ __ ] we're doing right now you know so I
kind of fall into these vices as well
right yeah but all the differences
between me and you is that I've done the
work and I've had the success you know
now I'm trying to rewrap it right so
you're not there yet yeah yeah I mean I
still have a thousand miles to go for me
right now like if people like what David
you still have a lot to go I was like
based on who I've already achieved
everything I wanted like I've yeah I've
had stand-up shows where I had like over
a thousand people there
I knocked those things out a couple
times it felt great right I don't care
to do it again I mean maybe in the
future who knows I wanted to do a film
did that [ __ ] yeah I wanted to open up
my own food concept I opened a five up
it was like I'm not flexing but I'm
saying like nine flags on them now now
it's time to be
like okay cool you got the hard work
done do you want to relax a bit now yeah
you know it's like do you want to just
like kind of smell the roads that's
where I'm at the stage right now that's
why I'm losing this weight this is the
time for me to smell the roses of the
bacon so like I'm in you smell a lot of
bacon yeah I'm trying to lose his way
get my health back and then kind of
focus on the stuff I didn't get the
focus while I was trying to grind out
and knock out my [ __ ] bucket list
right that's what [ __ ] I in my
personal opinion from me I mean I may
not seem like a lot to to most people
because people look for high stardom
they want to be in these Hollywood films
I've never had those dreams I just
wanted to help people by making them
laugh that's all my life goal is that's
what I live by everyday this podcast is
here to help people out the kind of
comedy was to help people out doing
music make people feel a certain way
everything that I've done up into this
point was because I wanted people to
feel good about themselves because when
I was younger I didn't feel good about
myself
so these are the small goals that I have
and it just kind of led to bigger things
that I expected yeah right so yeah I say
for me on my bucket list I probably
completed about 75% of it I only got 25%
of like personal stuff that I want to do
right and the rest is just when I have
kids I'm gonna give it all them and
that's about it it's 26 you got a lot
more to go yeah man
I've always wanted my butt out you know
26 sounds old to me because I've always
one of this [ __ ] since like like 15 and
I was like yo when I turn 18 it's gonna
be the Justin Bieber so ya know no real
talk it's funny you said that because I
used to be a Justin Bieber hater
actually I actually talks [ __ ] about his
yummy track which really I was just
eating again I was hating on it and I
was on another content piece of content
so I was really trying to make my
opinion sound super thin but I was like
yo it's a flop said but um I hated on
him because my favorite my favorite
artist bro uh sure
chose Justin Bieber of course and I was
like what the [ __ ]
like I was like my thing was like I'm
supposed to be signed so then is
Bieber's 26 - he's like 24 25 okay
no he might be 25 26 maybe we may be the
same in like 24 it's Justin Bieber
Bieber Bieber I've been [ __ ] up his
name is Justin Bieber yeah just I think
I'm doing with the Asian accent for so
long I don't even remember anymore
it's Justin Bieber
yeah Justin Bieber look yeah okay head
um so yeah he got to speaker okay picked
up by us your bro and I you know he was
a kid and and he was doing the whole
side moonwalk because I should talk
about dude cyber walking I was like I've
been knowing I do that [ __ ] like I was
like I was really hating on the [ __ ] so
then I was like alright [ __ ] imma have
Chris Brown picked me up right so now I
literally made a documentary I problem
imma bring it back out but I've made a
whole documentary of like Who I am what
I do all the different things I have a
boxing section an acting section art
section and dance it's all broken down
into four sections in this documentary
but it all goes down to why Chris Brown
should sign me right and I would he beat
up Rihanna and you're like [ __ ] okay
whoa we're not gonna go there listen he
beat the [ __ ] [ __ ] out of her
okay he just he did Muay Thai on her
face
I'm sorry team breezy but I'm still with
you guys all right makes great music but
that that boy [ __ ] knocked her to
another universe
wagwan like just bishop hey man you know
you heard his side right what was his
side muted I want to hear his side she
never did not not a joke oh yeah pardon
his face he was like what the [ __ ] no no
no bro like it was uh you know this is
all on you know on the on his
documentary that he put on nephew put
his hands on him first huh a whole it
was a whole situation bro put his hands
on them and you know she's like grabbed
his dick and like tried to like squeeze
they rip that [ __ ] off yeah it was the
whole thing I believe him
you know yeah it was like you know there
there were they were they were fighting
yeah you know they they were throwing
blows you know what the funny thing is I
did this in a stand-up set Oh years ago
which doesn't justify I'm not I'm not
saying I'm literally just I'm literally
just reiterating what he said in yeah
Chris likes women to get beat listen and
we know but you know like people were
wondering what the other side was
there's no jaw hit when people do this
to they go what do you need no other
side is a woman who got beat right what
if the other side was that she try to
rip his dick off yeah yeah well I'm
nobody's justifying that somebody got
beat up yeah but we all know what
in this real world and you've seen it
that were sometimes certain women they
believe that they could put their hands
on a guy whenever they want because
they're like you know what you're not
gonna touch me either way sometimes you
get touched up a little bit especially
if you try to snatch a dick off a guy
yeah it might happen I'm not saying it's
okay
but I it's kind of interesting to know
the story there's no judgment here
my part because I don't know what
happened right and plus they're they're
cool now right their friends is [ __ ]
yeah sure yeah I'm sure they're doing it
yeah yeah they actually were started
they dated again at one point yeah they
did it again and then you know if
whatever love triangle we had going on
and then yeah they're just in there
splitting but yeah he'll throw a couple
emojis and [ __ ] on her page every now
and then yeah I think there's a reminder
of love I'll again looked at you know
saying I think Chris Brown noticed that
low yeah but um but yeah so I had this
whole thing of like you okay fine Chris
Brown Xena saw me and then I like I
remember like he performed in Houston
one time and like I finessed my way into
like sneaking into the VIP
meet-and-greet met him told him a man I
plan on moving to LA someday I plan on
working with you someday he's like oh
man that's what's up man this was like
that's tight and he socked you up a bit
I made out I remember I designed him and
printed a shirt from because that's when
I was running my t-shirt business too
and so I was like I scream for this
shirt for him gave him a custom shirt
and then you know fast forward like a
few years later I moved to LA and I
ended up booking this this deal where I
present Chris Brown his vivo certified
awards for like YouTube type [ __ ] whoa
do you remember you the hell no you
remember me but I told him the story I
told him that yo man I told you that I
was gonna you know like ah that's cool I
don't remember you at all [ __ ] yeah and
it was I was looking away technically
not working together but it was like you
know it was still cool it was cool that
I like I guess that was like a check you
know I mean but I still would like to do
look collab you know me and like like
you try to be a singer I was trying to
be a singer actor dancer like I wanted
to be all of it oh yeah I still would
like to do music for sure but I have
already accepted idea that can't sing I
tried
like I was a vocal coach I mean yeah but
but I know how to hold a note but the
thing is like I wanted to sing I want to
be like a badass singer I don't want to
just be getting by yeah that was my
thing so I was just like what's your
favorite Chris Brown song right now my
favorite Chris Brown song oh damn uh
what is my favorite Chris Brown song is
that puberty Chris Brown or a
pre-puberty Chris Brown um I would go
with I'm gonna go with I like I like
give me that and that's not really like
a singing one I want you to sing it for
us right now I don't know what give me
that sounds like oh no I'm not even a
song that's not even like really like
singing he's just like give me that and
you're looking when you lay what I like
oh yeah
yeah I like that one because of the
dancing like the dancing was looking
badass there was a song like I would
[ __ ] I would I would really try to
sing this song it was like um oh I
should have kissed you or something like
yeah I should have kissed you I would
really try to be like and house kissed
you like I would really like try I'm not
gonna give you the [ __ ] real one I'm
gonna just keep acting like a [ __ ] it
[ __ ] it up but a smart man yeah I'm
not gonna lie smart like that yeah yeah
you know it seems like every time give
me mine yeah yeah I'm [ __ ] my thing
it is bro and like I really wanted to
bro I was like it and my thing was like
I'll get out nail everything else and
then just throw a lot of tune on me you
know that's what everybody is so I was
like I was like alright Chris will [ __ ]
with me if this is the only thing that I
can't really get down it's not
hundred-percent like I probably maybe if
I can get in with like a 60 you know but
I got the dancing dad get this down like
yeah for sure but then I finally like I
finally when I moved to LA it ended up
being about like what am I trying to
find somebody to like sunt like to you
know sign me or so to speak you know me
path yeah yeah and I had to and man
hi everybody bomber but body a lot of
people were like so they've supported it
there they didn't tell me they were to
tell me like that's dumb the [ __ ]
wrong with you because I was so driven
bro you remember that time when I was
doing it I mean nobody nobody could tell
me [ __ ] I was like Chris Brown's gonna
see this documentary he's gonna be like
where is this kid that's the funniest
[ __ ] thing in my life if you met me
at that age I would have threw eggs at
you yeah I would've thrown rotten apple
at your face I still have all that
shaver I'm not the one you would've came
out to me yo Dave man let me tell you my
dream I'm making this documentary it got
singing it got a painting yeah it got
dancing and Chris Brown's gonna sign me
I was like no that one time I slapped in
the face and I three overbridge it was
like what's that I slap in the face the
[ __ ] is wrong with you man would you say
whatever he does think of something like
that like he doesn't really get so
determined motivation see exact what
you're talking about when you get hyped
on something you guys that's what that's
how Joe is Joe is like that when Joe
finds a hobby he hones in so hard he got
recently not too long ago he's not gonna
cry anymore but he got super into karate
this [ __ ] was doing karate
Coty's all [ __ ] day for like a year
doing the belt test and all this other
[ __ ] and it was just he was [ __ ]
Daniel Larusso in the Karate Kid
out of nowhere so he's like you were he
gets super hyped up about stuff and he
hyper laser focus on that one [ __ ]
thing yeah I actually listened to
y'all's uh that episode man the three
simple steps of like success oh yeah Oh
bro that I listened to it last night
actually to be honest with you because
you actually I think you you posted it
on your story
yeah because somebody was like this is
actually the most important podcasters
design and you were like it definitely
is so I went to go listen to it and I
was like this is [ __ ] Joe cuz I saw the
video that he put out about his class
that would thing that he's doing and I
actually wanted to tell Joe man I was
like man you he actually he gave so much
in that in that intro video of like this
is why she take the class I was like I
basically took the class
the class is more specific oh yeah yeah
for sure for sure but he was it was it's
almost like coming out with a book and
then telling them what your book is
about not like oh damn like you got you
know you got people just like motivated
what I mean either way it would still be
a win for him if just that got him like
his purpose in life is that is to help
people you know yeah and like that the
hard part is it's like all this stuff
that we said on that podcast it's
enlightening for a lot of people and
sometimes stuff that people have already
heard the problem is just like they
don't know how is that problem right
that's where his program really helps is
the how and it's that one-on-one because
like I've told people the same advice
over and over and over and the reason
why when we talked on that podcast is
like we always talked about people
always get hyped up to do something but
they just never know about the execution
right and one of the things I didn't say
on that podcast is what everybody sounds
like to me this is this is a this is 99%
of the population when it comes to
achieving something everybody always
says this thing they go do you want to
try this thing I would love to cool why
don't you start doing it ah
because already three reasons it's
always it's always like this you always
have three reasons no but only one
reason yes yeah three reasons why you
should why you can't do something but
only one reasons why you can yeah and
that you've already failed at the gate
like it's impossible the first person
that doubts you is actually yourself and
when when it really requires action and
thought people just don't do it and
that's the hard part right right because
I'm I'm adding time to my parking bow
and I look like a reason why we broke up
yeah let's work it out work it out but
yeah that's that's the hard part it's
just like kind of getting their foot in
the door in the right way instead of
just getting into it because you're
hyped it's really finding out why you're
doing this and then working on the how
after that's the hard part yeah yeah
that's why I'm always talking about
figuring out why you're doing something
because you could always go back to it
it gives you laser focus
you see I'm saying yeah I don't know if
you have seen that movie of The Legend
of Bagger Vance which is like that's
like the whole theme I guess of that
entire movie that you're battling like
yourself basically an entire life I mean
that's
the ultimate thing that the other movies
like the climax that your hmm he's
trying to get like that last shot that
cuz like a golf movie basically a Matt
Damon he's got like some shot in the
woods or some [ __ ] that he can't make or
it's like super hard to make her
something like that and uh his caddie
who's Will Smith you know tries to coach
he coaches up a little bit about you
know telling him about his insight like
you know you're you're capable of this
kind of thing and trying to get past
that yourself like you're saying you
know it's like you're your own kind of
like wall your own demon your own thing
as you're battling your entire life and
that movie was like based off of old
Indian proverb kind of thing which is
the old book called
bhagavad-gita which is kind of like
Bagger Vance it's supposed to be kind of
thing and that's really what it is in
the entire time which is you're battling
yourself so if like you're saying you're
self doubting yourself you're already
like yeah it's a self-fulfilling
prophecy
you're like you've already felt before
you even start it exactly because you
already had that mind say that you
weren't going to succeed it's such a
hard thing for people to get past right
also a lot of people are just afraid of
failure and failure is the best [ __ ]
teacher in life when you fail at things
you don't really go backwards you
actually level up yeah you always level
up when you fail yeah without unless you
take that failure and you make the same
mistake like a dumb [ __ ] then yeah
you're back at the same place you know
but failure is - it's the biggest
teacher ever it's like oh I tried this
out I found out this isn't for me then
you move on you take those life lessons
and you and you level up in life yeah
and people are so scared of failing
because they think the whole world is
watching them hey guys let think about
it nobody gives a [ __ ] about you you're
not that [ __ ] important you're an
important person you're not that [ __ ]
important mmm which is something you
should really think about cuz you go out
there you know the other day right I'm
trying to do this thing where I'm biking
now right check it out didn't tie my
shoes my [ __ ] got caught up in my chain
I fully to a bush to a bush people were
done you know how fun why would it be
I'm in Pasadena all white people right
tell me why tell me [ __ ] why the one
black dude in suburban had to watch me
go into a bush ago haha I was like why
why dog and I just sat there I had to
sit there
in my [ __ ] bike chain like this
undoing it and that dude just had to go
oh I'm like damn this is Pasadena why
did you come out here right now perfect
balance bro like when when everything is
going good and life you're just chillin
bike right and then that that low like
humbling moment of laughing this was
Bush this is reality yo this is reality
it's funny cuz I felt my laces
tightening as the thing was all I could
think was like there's nothing I can do
about this I just gotta good [ __ ] and I
just fell right into a bush and that was
it and I just had to get up like nothing
happened I started cycling off again
life and that's failure man it's okay be
somebody laughs at you that that dude
left what's gonna happen after I'm still
alive yeah people don't think about the
after part of failing you're still alive
nothing's gonna happen there's there's
really no there's there's no consequence
of failing really in trying something
new right unless unless you know it's
like hey I'm gonna try to get shot in
the face to see what happens that's a
little different you having but majority
the stuff that we want to try there
isn't that many major consequence uh-huh
yeah unless you really dive deep let's
say you're working a [ __ ]
nine-to-five and you go hey I want to
try music well you could do it after
work and try that out but even then when
there's no consequence of trying that
out people don't do it cuz they're like
what are my friends gonna think when I
try music maybe I'm not a good singer
well if I go out and sing in front of
somebody they're probably gonna make fun
of me they're gonna laugh I'm not that
good I'm not gonna it's like [ __ ] man
how do you live in that type of
self-doubt try it out if you fail you
[ __ ] fail that is what it is yeah
that's well that's what it is right to
live after you if they felt once it's
like it's so demoralizing to them for
some reason and even if they fail two or
three more times it's still like still
do more or less then once you get past
the point of like failure like 10 times
20 times then it kind of like becomes
less numbing - you know like acting I'm
the first time I ever went to my real
audition when I got signed I read this
role [ __ ] hilariously funny I was so
stupid I didn't realize that the the the
episode was like for like a CSI or
something it wasn't a funny role but for
some reason I interpreted in my [ __ ]
psychotic head as a comedic role and
then after when I was done with the
audition the person look at me he goes
that was a very interesting take so what
oh the comedy route and i looked and i
sat there i was like cuz it's not a car
so this is a serious part where somebody
died in the scene and for some reason i
thought it was funny you're reading it
like ah you're killing me killing me
right now
I went into my car I pulled the seat all
the way back I laid down to that way I
scream I was mortified that I called my
boy Kaleem I like Doug this is what just
happened he goes Amen that's just this
is acting welcome back yeah right and I
thought I just kept over I was like well
nothing's ever gonna get divorces that
never did I never did that again so I
just now i skabble right you go to the
auditions I walk in walk out and it is
what it is that's it man I've been on
the other side of our dishes to where
now I'm like oh yeah it's really out of
your control
it is the only thing you can do here
yeah it's about to say only things you
can do as an actor get off book killed
work your ass off on that little slot
side that they give you sometimes you
get blessed with giving getting the
whole script so you can actually read
the whole thing you get context and
everything but most of the time you just
get aside and you have to figure out on
your own whether it's a comedy or a
[ __ ] si si si si the first thing you
guys should do probably understand the
scene yeah and not make a joke once it
has their blame their brains blown out
yeah so you know and then go in there
and [ __ ] do your best and kill it and
then walk out and forget about it yeah
not in your control anymore it's not in
your control forget don't think about
man if I get that wrong I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna damn my house well but
you know no just forget about that [ __ ]
yeah that's what I remember when they
had that huge jackpot for the lottery of
my ghetto ass I already planned out my
life yeah for when when I win yeah I
already planned out my life yeah and
when I didn't win I was pissed I was
like what why don't you pissed it wasn't
guaranteed you [ __ ] I was like
okay well I was going to get his boat I
was going to [ __ ] retire my parents I
guess not hold on a second no what do
you say you dumbass I was like pissed
all week I was like I can't believe I
didn't win
honor the lottery of all things the one
thing that you have point zero zero
eight percent chance of winning or some
joke i remember my grandpa man he played
a lot he plays a lot of every day right
and he's been playing it every day I
mean since I was you know a you know why
I says I can remember basically I just
grew up with him always telling us pick
a number one through ten and we'll say
six you know market okay pick a number
thirteen through thirty 22 and he'd be
market and he that that was like his way
of playing the lottery would do it with
us whatever and so I finally asked him
like you know I'm Lowell door now at
them like fifteen I'm like you know so
how does this how does his work you know
because I he would always tell us to go
by him the lottery ticket would go
whatever and so so he would uh wait were
we old enough to buy a lottery or did I
just lie
fifteen yeah well now how do you how do
you have to be a biologic to you I don't
know okay I probably [ __ ] lie but
anyway basically just like you know he
would we would get him you know bring
him his lottery tickets and so I'm like
you know how is this all where he's
explaining it and I was just like that
seems easy yeah and he he lost it it was
basically like all of the 67 years he's
been alive was just he was like
like he's been doing this [ __ ] every day
time oh there's a lottery [ __ ] easy I
was like yeah I mean what do you just
pick numbers and then they choose
numbers doing a [ __ ] lotto [ __ ] since
I was a kid to still hasn't won Hey and
that what my aunt odd I never get this
ship and my uh but it was way back man
my always plays um her kids and her
husband's birthdays that's the numbers
she's been doing this for years
right the one time she doesn't play
those numbers pop up but it's not
it wasn't like all of them to work she's
been a hold it but it was like like five
out of the six still went some money
from although she would have got
beaucoup and she was devastated so like
we're going to the beach and this was a
whole thing and like you know the
happiest place you get be you know me
and she was just devastated drown all
her kids oh my god and my
they're on her sister was just trolling
she did she had like a disposable camera
she just kept taking pictures of her
that's time just like she just kept
taking pictures of just how pissed she
was let's all just play the lotto man
we'll split it we'll split it three ways
I'm down and then we'll just be ball in
there then you can just be you know just
not doing anything [ __ ] is doing nothing
man you could paint all you want man you
try to give me money man you best
believe I'm doing [ __ ] oh I'm not doing
[ __ ] man I can't oh there that's what's
that's a shitty thing dude like I just
don't want to work for my [ __ ] anymore
that's what you said man dude he said
you work your ass off so that you don't
have to do [ __ ] that's that's the thing
like I look at Diddy he looks like Satan
- this looks like Satan man like I kid
you not
Diddy if you ever see this you're [ __ ]
Lucifer I don't give a [ __ ] I like there
and that's love I look at his face I'm
like you are Satan damn
the-the-the the minister side me says
you my friend are a fallen angel of
heaven it just looks evil everything
about his face just so [ __ ] evil yeah
he looks like did he don't even look
like a black dude to me he look like a
white dude doing blackface
he don't you know he looks weird today
uh-huh
like if you look at his face is like you
ain't you're not even human
you don't look human to me look at look
at pictures of Diddy's face like I've
recently saw that video it was like the
black billionaires luncheon yeah he's
given that speech Satan look at you just
see feet spear souls look at you just
spitting that fire and brimstone take
that yeah we over here we the black
billionaires I'm like nah you ain't
black no bro you Satan dudes you trying
to influence these beautiful black men
and do some crazy [ __ ] good that's why
jay-z was standing there looking all
confused he goes
little peculiar oh man that was a shitty
man that the Grammys bro especially
during the time of the same day kobe
diagram yo did you cry oh I bawled isn't
this so weird criterion like the day
after cuz I'm a part of the son of a
[ __ ] okay so so what happened with so
if we're like whenever whenever he pad
will first of all we were all doing you
what were you doing when you when you
pass I woke up and then I just saw a
tweet and all that's week I saw a tweet
it's like yo that Kobe it was like I
can't believe the thing about Kobe right
it was something very vague and I looked
it up online I was like I literally
tweeted I was like I Kobe think it real
right yeah and then next article next
article next article have been my
[ __ ] eye started welling up with
tears and [ __ ] yeah and then I found
that his daughter was there mm something
that guy I started imagining the fact
that his helicopters going down and he
has to hold his daughter and pretend
like everything's okay
and I found that there was other people
on the helicopter to it that [ __ ] got me
even more I'm like that wasn't just copy
it was him and then six whole family bro
a whole family I was like and was crazy
because I heard a calf talk about it and
mrs. Kim on stage they said that it was
just that that day was just an everyday
car pool situation of like oh yeah well
Richard show yeah we'll get y'all there
yeah for rich people's like okay yeah
hop in I'll cover would will go straight
there when we know play the game like it
was just a regular thing man and there's
I want to know why his [ __ ]
helicopter malfunction
man oh they said one of the things on it
like one day one of the I guess certain
machines that supposed to like track if
you're about to hit the cliff or
something like that it tells you like if
you're gonna clear it you didn't have
that machine built into it like it was
supposed to yeah yeah and then and they
would fall and there was a there was a
20 30 foot like clearing yeah yeah 20 to
30 feet and that machine would have told
them if you could make that kinda
yeah you're a cousin bro he hit me a
victor he was breaking it down to me
because apparently like he flies planes
and stuff okay and so he broke it down
was like he knows like just because of
like when when you're in fog it was that
all that fog you don't know whether
you're going up down left and right like
cuz it's that like yeah oh that's a
solid yeah then thick and so there's
that there's complacency as well of like
just like oh I got this instead of
really going through all the procedures
mm-hmm oh not me you find a helicopter
[ __ ] if my helicopter pilot I was like
oh some little foggy outside goes I got
this okay well I'm gonna step off real
quick yeah you figured that out dumbass
I got my daughter with me yeah I mean
and then and then it's also um he said
that uh the impact was just quick it was
like oh yeah a snap to where they don't
know where they were going
yeah to where you wouldn't even have
that you wouldn't even know to grab you
know - just like prepared though it was
just a straight but like that's it and
he was like that doesn't make it better
it's still a tragedy it's just the idea
of you know the one you see in the
movies of like the planes going down and
like that type of thing where you have
like a 30-second gap or many is death it
was just straight boom done why did they
why do you think he was just gonna
[ __ ] helicopter and fog that's what
I'm saying it's like oh man yeah there's
that mob mentality bro doing that for so
much of his life like at this point I
heard he's been doing since he was in
the NBA right yeah yes hey telly traffic
yeah and he wanted to spend that extra
20 30 minutes with his with his daughter
and so I didn't cry the day oh it was
super unbelievable it was shocking yeah
you know it was like it was yanked how
do you even take all that in it was so
much but I had to still perform that
night I had a show it was a stand-up for
Puerto Rico so I'm also doing a show for
the tragedy that happened in Puerto Rico
with the earthquakes and stuff you
should then a Kobe joke and okay I'm
[ __ ] around I'm playing well you
would have you would have lost your
whole career shoutouts to Ari Shaffir
yeah
it's oh yeah so so um I ended up like
still having to perform whatever and it
was an intimate room and it was super
supportive all the acts like I was the
only comic ever they did poetry they did
a music there's a band they just did
instrument instrumentals and stuff so um
everything was supportive whatever but I
even said it on stage I was like guys I
got beyond which I I did I I had no
intentions of being funny today like I
did really just it's just tough yeah I
mean um and I didn't even know if I was
gonna be like I thought I was gonna
probably cancel this but then I was like
it's not it's not even about me you know
me my event it's about the event it's
about making people feel good during
times like this you know I mean it was
like shout out to all the comics who
performed that night cuz it's like this
tragedy just happened we still got a
clock in and make people feel good
during this time maybe that wouldn't be
that [ __ ] right so it was tough man and
um it was it was the next day because I
live right down the street from the
Staples Center that's right so I walk
down there and this packed right nothing
but people as a whole bunch of people
with purple and gold okay everyone go
you know they're they're showing like
all the outdoor like restaurants like
where you have like the the tables out
during the TV's all the although the
games like the they showed the the final
Kobe game they replayed that one
everybody's like wearing Kobe jerseys
flowers everything all over the place
and they did the whole like uh they had
paper balls and they had a little trash
can and then they had like a big circle
around it bo buddies
hollering Kobe bro shooting it and I
went back home when I got back home I
decided to watch um the top 50 plays I
don't do it dude I watched top 50 plays
and it started from 50 going all the way
down I got to 48 calling bro just all
fluids coming out of my face and it was
like it was all so yeah bro I was crying
man and I didn't know anybody up I was
just like I had the cry that was like
I'm like kind of screaming like making
you know I mean like it kind of just
like
like really big and it was also like
what a [ __ ] I was a straight [ __ ] that
night but it was like um and also like
my personal [ __ ] too like I didn't even
break down with my whole like breakup
situation and I thought that was kind of
weird cuz I'm emotional like I thought
that was gonna come man I had a whole
breakdown of like everything just came
crashing down and was that gonna text
you after hearing this by the way say
holla you didn't you cried over and over
yeah you didn't [ __ ] cry right you
score 60 points on your last game before
you left you want where I'm shooting in
the jail oh yeah man that [ __ ] really
[ __ ] me up bro like it that and then
watching it's still weird it is it's
definitely because we weren't even over
we're not even over nipsey I'm not the
whole ditzy situation that [ __ ] [ __ ]
me up bro Mac like 20/20 is the ultimate
test bro everybody just be killing
themselves like a month in it's already
seems crazy the ultimate test bros like
how like it's like it was like oh yeah
new decade cool yeah we'll try this you
know or you're motivated try this and
how motivated are you you know I'm
saying that's how I took it the universe
was just like are you motivated cuz he
ain't think happen and then he's still
didn't post on Instagram like inspired
you to do some things you know morning
he's in the morning phase man it takes
like three months so he almost there but
the hard part the funny thing is like
you know when Ari Shaffir to put his
[ __ ] out write that tweet which was
[ __ ] a wild did you did you well we
got to read that [ __ ] out loud now Ari
Shaffir thing was so weird first of all
number one I'm not a hater right there's
a lot of people's comedy that I don't
understand but I'm like that like I see
why that's funny right it's just cuz
it's just not like this one do you not
makes well him in general I just never
laughed at anything he's ever done cuz
he just reminds me of an angry guy I've
never heard of the guy well I only
herded him through Joe Rogan okay so but
I preparin he's like a pretty well-known
comic okay like in the comic circle yeah
yeah but he just says a lot of [ __ ]
[ __ ] like angry [ __ ] [ __ ] but there's
no bro punchline that's what I feel like
I'm not some you know comedy connoisseur
but as a viewer as a listener I have an
opinion you know but then whenever he
came on the Joe Rogan podcast I'm like
who is this guy he's not even funny like
he's just angry all the time
angry without humor cuz you know bill
burr he's angry but he's funny yeah you
know even louis c.k he has his lo he's
irritated but it's funny it's
observational yeah with a guy in
Sweethearts when they get off like bill
birnes like his [ __ ] nicest [ __ ] when
I'm in oh I thought I was a little
nervous I thought he was gonna be like a
come on man [ __ ] a man yeah forgot him
but I was like okay he's cool he's cool
he's nice I got total miles from Houston
and like I was like man I performed up
there and he'll just like a man like you
know he was he was saying like you know
I performed and Pryor out there and like
you know if you're in town you know come
by see about getting a set type of thing
that's tight that's awesome dude you
know I'm saying I might have lied about
that last part all right well you know
what speaking into it yeah it's not
gonna happen
how about you [ __ ] Instagram post do
it stop there
Kobe Bryant died 23 years too late today
he got away with rape because all the
Hollywood liberals who attack comedy
enjoy rooting for the Lakers more than
they dislike rape Big Ups to the hero
who forgot to gas up his chopper I hate
the Lakers what a great day hashtag
[ __ ] the Lakers now I guess you could
say he's trying to be confrontational
with his jokes poor timing not the right
time nine people died and that the
funniest end daughter broke his
daughter's life is funny about that like
I don't even know now let me tell you
this though I did read another tweet
that actually had me giggle a little bit
about the death now I'm gonna put this
out there I did not write this tweet
mm-hmm but you're gonna laugh that that
you hear that okay the tweet goes Kobe
past
impossible another one that I saw that
was clever that they said because you
know they were doing the 24 second thing
all the all the teams over they grabbed
the ball they did the 24 seconds and
they said he said you know Kobe's up
there right now you know Kobe is such a
competitive player he's watching those
24-second violation like every [ __ ]
possession counts it's it's teetering on
that point of like yo he died but the
joke is funny still funny to me what is
the joke in this I'm trying hard to find
the joking in you know what I mean yeah
because I'm he posted something like a
video he doubled up on oh no I saw the
videos and that was the one I didn't
know about that tweet but I saw the
video of him like Kobe's God like he did
this hole I was like bro what is your
problem and then and then so he did this
thing of his latest post on his
Instagram where he's like it's like he
typed it up in his notes but he's
basically justifying the fact that every
time somebody dies his fans come to him
waiting for like yo when are you gonna
do your your piece of [ __ ] post like
they're like he it's like this is like
what he does you know I'm saying
and I'm like what out of all trends that
you could create out of all like things
that you know your fans can that's the
one you choose when someone dies you go
and say the opposite of what everybody
else is thinking I'm like this it's
low-hanging fruit yeah what do you cuz
then what happens when you die yeah what
happens in everybody's happy dude do
your followers dude do that towards you
and then and then is it and then is it
because I'm trying to think of like the
most basic typical response that he
could possibly say of like I would
[ __ ] love that my fans would my fans
would that would mean a lot to me
because that means my fans actually [ __ ]
with me to know that if I died they
would [ __ ] do the same [ __ ] that's a
[ __ ] obvious answer how would you
really feel your family like you know I
mean like how was your family feel they
everybody said I might happen to him
when he was a kid there's some there's
some [ __ ] up [ __ ] they had to it had
my own kid go off about the guy like
even listening to him I Joe Rogan's
podcast I'm a huge fan of Joe Rogan and
then you know when he has like Bert
Kreischer and so he also like dosed his
friend Bert Kreischer where oh he
drugged him and had me go all loopy
without telling him so he dosed him and
the Bert Bert well-known comedian too
didn't talk to him for quite a while
because he was so pissed
and I guess Bert's wife [ __ ] hate
sorry for that [ __ ] cuz he [ __ ] drug
the man without telling him and he
thought it was funny
so he's just a [ __ ] [ __ ] he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's really what it is
you know and I don't know people can try
to protect him his friends like I he's
still a good guy not [ __ ] really man
it's probably because he's good to you
but as a general human being he's still
a piece of [ __ ] yeah like I had homies
who were really nice to me right growing
up doesn't mean they didn't do like a
drive-by a shot people up than in jail
yeah well cool to me yeah but they're
not good people right I mean like know
the [ __ ] difference yeah and who and
who's gonna who and his circle is gonna
tell him like nah bro that was yeah I
did what it is to right you know I'm
saying like didn't check the same way
like so much I check [ __ ] what's the
name r kelly is it like come on man like
yeah like that's why I [ __ ] with my
circle cuz it's like they'll tell me
straight up that was some dumb [ __ ]
bottom box the first person you know
we're not you take pissing on a 40 no
girls i hey man probably not the moves
like dicks in your head no no no no man
I mean I just let it go
well don't shake it ya know the part to
that are Kelly docking documentary yeah
they're milking that [ __ ] I was like
what's the part two about he did it yeah
and now the girl is like now she is like
out of it like she is it broke out of
the you know little spell spell and now
she's doing the whole thing I'm like
she's been exposing and like saying all
these things like yeah he would make us
do this he'd make it too then and
somebody commented I was like I'm over
this saga yeah well they're milking it
now that's why they're kind of turning
the whole like it's it's a serious
situation but now it just seems like a
money grab now you just make a joke out
of the situation it's like we get it you
know I mean and it's it's a it's a sad
[ __ ] story yeah but it comes off for
some reason I don't know why the part
two comes off this ingenuously the first
one it seemed very genuine second one
and even the first one from you by the
way I don't know if a lot of people felt
like this but I felt like it dragged its
like you definitely could have shortened
this into like two or three parts yeah
but you wanted to have it to be four or
five or whatever like you could have
shorten this up and they felt the
long for me and I was like oh this is
definitely a money grab for people so
when something like that that's also
very heartfelt feels like it's just a
money thing it takes it takes away from
from me a little bit not from their pain
or what they went through but as a
viewer watching a documentary yeah where
is where is art Kelly I don't know after
that whole Gale thing that [ __ ] was
crazy yo thing Gail oh you do want the
interview
ya know what a hawk I shut the [ __ ] up
country boy
yeah the country boy wasn't he I believe
so yeah you open a country you like the
country a little farm boy yeah that's
probably the first thing he learned how
to do ya like that ya know you're
supposed to put a gag in her mouth first
but like nobody said anything about that
mr. Kelly yeah man I don't know because
I was just like he's been playing it
like real low-key like rewsey is he like
you know you know he's not in jail yet
though but I'm he's gonna go as he was
but then he got he getting a home girl
home girl got him out paid a hundred G's
and now she wants it back
she's like um you are gonna take him
back to prison can I get my money back
no lady nah he posted bail for anything
that's crazy how much people yo you
heard the the like he already had pretty
obviously the evidence of him just
pissing on a grill which is [ __ ]
disgusting and terrible
he had a concert in Africa did you hear
that [ __ ] mm-hmm it was like if the song
goes like did you get your shots would
you like to come with Rob to America
that's the [ __ ] song and he's singing
at a benefit concert did you get your
shots would you like to come through
with Rob to America like what the [ __ ]
is going on
amen that is like he knows that he has
angel vocals and with that confidence
he's like yeah I'll sing my way I'll get
them to do whatever I want
amen what's it called [ __ ] uh sure
did a whole album called confessions and
confessions part 2 about him cheating
and having a kid on the side and women
still love him what are MB does to
ladies is unfuckin real dad
that's who that's what made me want to
do it real talk look I became look
rushers concert was the first concert
that I've ever been to
right I was like eight or nine whatever
and he was 8701 8701 album and this is
why I was like I wanted to be either
that like an RB singer pop pop soon or
whatever or just an entertainer in
general because I saw one guy on a stage
and a whole stadium just like screaming
for this guy I'm coming I like any move
he did take his glasses off and then she
was going crazy ripped his shirt and I
was just like yo you want that like I
want to do that yeah you know I'm saying
like and then when I performed on stage
for the first time I felt the energy
that I would like that that people
thought until performer man that
entertainers talk about entertainers
talk about that of like the energy and I
felt that [ __ ] I was like yeah
that's what that's what gets me off I
don't care what I'm doing that acting in
plays
I did I did theater I did um on the
talent shows but I would dance I
wouldn't I didn't want to think so I
would just dance though so I would do
whatever song Chris Brown whatever and
dance to it and we get the same
adrenaline and then now stand-up
favorite uh sure song oh I'll give you
three top three okay Tucker here goes
you remind me you don't have to call and
you got a bet 8701 damn that's hard to
say I would say [ __ ] [ __ ] actually we
might have the same ones actually
confessions Part two I actually really
really like mm-hmm
when he flipped that up I thought that
[ __ ] was dope the main like confessions
yeah
it was the remix version but yeah that
[ __ ] was [ __ ] fine yeah put that up
there and then I also got what's it
called um what was your three again
you remind me you don't have to call and
you don't have to call it's definitely
one of them for sure
yeah and then whoo that's hard that you
don't leave it girl around me true
player for real as my [ __ ] for real
Oh bro when he slid into the bathroom it
has been a tad she's tiny bro every time
I have fog on my mirror I always do the
wipe today and I always do that same
situation about don't mind huh like girl
I don't mind that one
no I'm sure always gonna have bangers no
no I felt like that was one of the ones
I was up there they're not my favorite
not one of my top three no I love it
though when I karaoke it's always oh
wait hold on you made it one no it's
actually I always do a couple it's you
got it bad or I do the Alicia Keys oh my
boot my boot yeah you know to karaoke
song whoo
now let's get somebody because you get
somebody else to do with yeah let me
know bro call me love yeah and then um
so with you
so with you make me wanna I've always
wanted to that song you made me want to
leave you the one on it I always wanted
esse Nereo bro like I've always wanted
like cuz I had this crush on this girl
for the longest like elementary school
and middle school and stuff like that
and then I would go I would have a
girlfriend but it would be this girl
that I always wanted to be like you
maybe want to leave the one I'm with to
get with you to start a new relationship
with you yeah this is what you do yeah
exactly and all the things that come
along with it you make me you make me
want to leave the one about
are you seeing works to me right now
nice my work before me that came between
us you were like my best friend you
should talk to when we micro were having
problems
oh yeah you wanted your own Angelina man
yeah yeah yeah I actually like I based a
lot of my life around
I think I'm kind of seeing this trope
right now then you gotta take a picture
for self but nakedness thought it was
some skinny ass legs yeah dick pic and
everybody was just clowning on his
[ __ ] tiny ass legs like what the
Ethiopian lays dog and why do you take
you like though yeah who does accepted
that would blur not the picture of his
dick it's that was like bro but look at
the legs guy Crypt Keeper what the [ __ ]
is going on you moonwalk your legs off
bro like a sidestep that [ __ ] down to
nothing yeah like burnt matches on him
dude it's like come on bro to get into
the weight room there's some [ __ ]
squats before you post your legs like
that man
oh man your boy who works legs yeah who
does legs hey come on angrily I got it I
did a little legs today for the first
time in a long time hit that squat son
yeah and a lot of [ __ ] started popping
for sure I will even when I get off this
couch i'ma fall through that glass
window it's gonna be a rough day
tomorrow and I think I'm gonna hiking
tomorrow to our unite we're at the
depends on what the lady wants to go
Hollywood sign on the back side of your
face oh really
there's a driest [ __ ] there there's no
nature there it's not a hike that's just
a angled road well it's it's it's yeah
we go we do the angles it's the incline
about it you know I mean a hike you're
talking about a hike like you bar ngo do
your guys are in like the Foresters [ __ ]
yeah but it's not a workout it doesn't
work yeah the right one okay though 20
which one was that one that I went to
that last one
I'll take y'all to a couple stops
pictures every other we can't tell
people the name because we want people
to be there it's like a little secluded
okay yeah we'll take you out to get a
couple spots yeah yeah if I get real
tired though but I like the ones that
are
you know the lucky ones yeah there's the
one next to my place that a lot of
people go to it's like three miles total
there and back it's not that hard but
it's very beautiful as scenic and
there's a part where you have to cross
the river and there's a waterfall and
then you might sprain an ankle a couple
times but you pretty good nice yeah man
I'll show you around
yeah I mean yeah yeah I'm a Nature Boy
now dude I'm down for the get-down yeah
I love that [ __ ] I found out too that
dogs really like me on these hikes for
some reason I'm about me that dogs
really like oh what the [ __ ] it's about
but I'm just walking around and
Meredith's honesty I just sat down I
smell like bacon and so I said I sat
down and then all of a sudden like four
dogs were just laying around me and Mary
I was like what the [ __ ] is this I was
like I don't know since I was a kid just
dogs just do this is the things you're a
kid it's like some real weird [ __ ] like
I love dogs too but I feel like I don't
love dogs like white people love dogs
yeah I mean when they let them tongue
their mouth and [ __ ] but I like dogs but
my mom she's like dogs really like you
dogs and babies like me a lot it was
because I'm dumb as [ __ ] like I just
like I got nothing in my mind and like I
could trust him why would she yeah they
identify when like dogs and baby like
buddy of my Jason like he has a daughter
she's like 1 years old like a my
daughter's a little standoffish she
doesn't lock a lot of people this girl
was staring at me all day Clark climbing
all over me
how's that amen I heard that that was a
sign of endearment when babies are just
staring at you it's because babies like
they actually know that you're like a
good-looking person like here it's it's
attracting but they don't know the idea
of like not to stay or whatever it's
just they're so fascinating
Oh or that that was I would prefer that
an adult woman but I get that from a
child so baby I want an adult sexy woman
to look at me like that just like stare
at me be like wow you are attractive
yeah I would be weird that now that I
know that and I see a baby staring mmm I
stop it me like that always
I would me mug for sure popping me
mugging I'd be trying to get them to cry
while you tell me things cry man I just
think it's funny cuz you know what it is
it has a person I've ever made happen to
me and that's all it is I'm just trying
to like do the same [ __ ] I'm just trying
to keep
second going but I have a like I would
I'd like how to staring for I still have
a staring problem like when I Drive and
I pass somebody I always look and to see
who it is
then not isn't that they don't have to
cut me off or anything but I always just
look inside people's cars I've gotten
called out about that all time like my
girl would be like why are you in their
car and I'm like oh and she's low-key
called me out I but I was like looking I
always look in people's [ __ ] so anyway
when I was younger I was in the barber
shop and this guy came in and you know
he just comes and sits on the chair and
kind of just gets settled
and I'm staring watching the whole thing
and I remember he he crossed his arms
and he sees me and little dope takes
teasing I'm staring and he goes right
and I got so scared like I was like I
was like oh snap you know like you know
you were staring yeah I didn't catch it
but he did that like this is a grown
adult you know me and I'm only like
eight you know all these stories happen
at eight I had a crazy eight-year-old oh
but yeah he did that he did a little
buck at me no yeah ya know and and I got
I remember getting so scared when that
and I guess it was came out oh yeah so
no fart little big boy you stare at me
the whole time just gonna fart on me
like that yeah so then I just started
like all right like I when I became that
I was like let me keep that trend going
I guess y'all make me feel like [ __ ]
about it yeah maybe not step so much of
people like yeah I didn't we learn from
that moment you know I I'm a people
watcher I observe it yeah yeah I feel
like your stock continues to go up on
the genius brain podcast if I were you
cheating on your woman I just staring at
people that's polite then you try to
really [ __ ] up your whole career
nice challenges that's this thing that's
why he doesn't want to post he doesn't
want to put himself out there
he wants to prove to people that no
matter how [ __ ] far down he pushes
his career he'll climb right the [ __ ]
yeah cuz you got people like re that I
could just be like hey Ari Shaffir
though right that's right you ain't that
bad yeah my homie actually said that -
he was like bro you
you're like incriminating yourself no
way I'm like I'm just speaking my truth
like it's true Wendy's I don't really
know how to just keep [ __ ] in and it's
actually healthy for me to just get that
[ __ ] out yeah but yeah I think it's a
comic it's just better for us to just
put our [ __ ] garbage out there
because the moment somebody tries to
find out some [ __ ] about us it's like I
already said that story dude
all right told you like when like the
whole n-word topic got high mmm they're
like people were acting as if they'd
never use that word in their life and
they were pointing fingers a lot yeah
but I'm like shut the [ __ ] up you for
sure said the n-word cuz I was there
when you used it right now that it's a
it's a hot topic you're like I can never
use it you don't have to say you never
used it because growing up in Sacramento
I said there's multiple times it was the
[ __ ] thing we said it all the time I
only realized that after I moved out of
Sacramento one came to LA how weird it
was to use it and I got checked yeah you
know they're like yo don't say that [ __ ]
I'm like why like everybody says around
from yeah it's like nah it's not cool
like that over here
I'm like oh hmm and realize that and
then you know like you know keV did a
topic on it and [ __ ] doughboys from
Sacramento - yeah he knows what's up
everybody says the n-word of Sacramento
this day everybody does to this day so
like I was a so when I go back to sac
everybody's still using it and it's
weird when I don't use it
mm-hmm so they're like oh it was being a
little weird it's like it's like and
they always get it out of me - so every
time I go back to sac I try not to my
hardest but then everybody using it
around me and I grew up in the moon my
parents own a black beauty supply store
I grew about in a predominantly black
neighborhood yeah and a lot of my
friends were black so I was like yo this
is I was incepted I got my black I got
my black heart he lands in Sacramento
just goes home unravel
because people don't know like I find it
weird when people who didn't grow up
around black culture people they don't
have black friends they don't know
anything about you know like just the
black American plight they don't know
any of this stuff and they feel like
it's okay to use it yeah yeah you know
I'm saying they see it as it's just a
word they see it as you know yeah I know
i yeah that's the weird thing you know
so like for me when somebody comes up
they go you shouldn't use them like yeah
you're probably right
you know what cuz I don't need you yeah
it's not a necessity why do I have to I
don't have to you know if it's if if the
time now is don't use that word that's
what it is
dump it and move on yeah cares that's
the thing taken away from me nothing's
being taken away from me yeah you know I
was the same thing with the FA G yeah
saying that like cuz back home that you
know I got homies who still use that
word and I cringe yeah cuz of like yeah
I've thrown that word route like around
whenever you know back when it was like
yeah it's not even it wouldn't even
about being gay it was just you know
yeah oh stop being this that being you
know me so I would just like that was
the thing but now like when I go and
they're still saying like and just like
throwing it out I'm like I'm like kind
of like looking around like yo chill bro
yeah yeah and now I kind of like I kind
of already like talk to them about of
like a bro look I I'm not gonna change
you you can say what you want but like
I'm just chillin on standing around me
yeah it's like I'm not trying to you
know I mean like oh and then they forced
it out of me too you know I forgot yeah
but yeah we see is that we're all the
time too and you know it's funny because
yeah like it was just the world we use
never said it against somebody who was
actually gay so it was it never had that
kind of day yeah yeah but if somebody's
like yo that's mad offensive and like
that's what the majority of people are
saying right and that is what it is move
on yeah I'm gonna move on right you know
occasionally will slip out probably but
then I'll try my best not to good people
to understand I was saying it for like
20 30 years so now that it's not this is
also gonna take some time for me to
learn that it's inappropriate so this
isn't there's no malice in it it's just
a habit and then if when I got checked
by it I accepted it didn't argue
yeah I never spent didn't be like I need
to use the word [ __ ] no no it's not
it's not right I got [ __ ] slipped out
sorry about that won't do it again yeah
yes true I would like to check myself
now say like [ __ ] in like places
it almost yeah yeah yeah cuz it was just
so common yeah I mean like people have
to understand like for me not to use the
n-word took my spirit soul and a lot of
prayers because I used it for every link
yeah I mean yeah what's up my everything
and then I didn't realize how much I
used it you know and because it was so
commonplace mm-hmm that and you feel me
what I used to say [ __ ] all the time
you know what I'm saying all the time
yeah those three things those three
words what I said so much and then when
I was recording myself I didn't realize
how often I use it to describe how I
felt 24/7 yeah you feel me oh yeah I
didn't know that either to read the
comments they're like yeah who wants to
count on your time so to say you know
I'm saying yeah me too
like it was like I'm saying you mean you
feel then I mean yeah all right okay you
feel me you don't know me yeah get it
all out you don't sum up yeah I will say
I do miss the N word though it was it
was like a period at the end of end of a
sentence that didn't that there's no
period on the same you got my okay you
barely there yeah that's a I've barely
made it was funny is that like even at
all dev I um I was you know just talk
whatever is said is chilling and nobody
was like hey uh hello are we letting
social same and I was like he said
Daniel ignite that's another thing too
I'm not gonna say you're [ __ ] explain
myself D history you know me and I got
it
I got black in me bro it's just that's
it you know a lot of it you know me say
it's same with bottie this is that it's
our heritage yeah we got if that's where
we came from we can't do [ __ ] about it
and we've got African in us yeah they
just made some stops at a few islands
before they came to the big one yeah I'm
saying but it's not but again even
saying that makes it seem like it's just
sounds corny because it's like oh so
you're you're you're
looking for the reason of why you said
it like let me do my research of like
yes I can use it no it wasn't even about
that it was just like yeah like we
always talk about the the there's no
universal pass for it so it's like if
you're back at home and you say to
around your boys and your homegirls and
[ __ ] no and they're cool with it and
they don't because even within the black
community right
I mean kev-kev video showed it there's a
disparity some people I don't ever
[ __ ] use it yeah and then there's the
other per site why can't we use it like
we switch the meaning of it it's like
it's like a 50/50 chance of wash yeah so
but then that's within the black
community to figure out that's not us
okay everybody on the outside we're just
outsiders but if you know you're using
them back home if I would say something
is like who you should be smart enough
to know if you're if you're black homies
allow you to say that [ __ ] that's only
in your area Yeah right would you walk
outside you're responsible yeah figure
it out whatever happens to you happens
to you right because you weren't smart
enough to know that around this group it
was cool and I'm pretty sure you're
always would be like why the [ __ ] were
you saying that [ __ ] another exactly I
mean like what's wrong with you bro like
you supposed to just say that all right
nothing nobody told me right yeah well
y'all that wraps up this episode the
genius brain podcast uh shout outs all
your shits all right y'all can follow me
on all platforms at Christy no salsa no
H of my name is CRI st Ino SOS a WoW
you can find me on instagram @ Bachrach
bah KR o HK yeah check out their podcast
keeping a trail yeah man we got a
podcast man it's popping man right now
we're on a Spotify and iTunes and we
getting things popping uh we're deep
into or like 46 it yeah 46 47 whereas a
lot episodes man yeah bro every week
chime in
even the trail baby you could catch the
genius brain podcast on all platforms
remember we're just here to be with you
on your everyday commute talking
[ __ ] random stuff sometimes is
really smart other times the stupidest
[ __ ] for example the origin of the word
- forgot
so forgot I forgot how that went how'd
it go I forgot
so let me also say your uh your your ads
sound [ __ ] phenomenal do they Oh bro
I like I was listening to excited cuz I
was actually like I put my Milo like a
bluetooth speaker right next to my bed
now laying down listening to y'all where
and then you hit your your ad and I was
like who is this like sound so like it's
like like I was like a professional
radio like that the ones that do the
actual commercials you know said it
sounds hello official bro Thank You Man
you know voice off work get me there
dude yes my guess is brought to you by
Apple baby so I want try to bring like
perfectly have you ever waking up and
then your laptop never worked before
well that's probably because you have
something that's not an Apple you've
been on a Mac OS for a very long time
where have you been yeah I'm saying
working on those ad dollars by the way
hooters if you need a sponsor hit me a
highboy hahaha see y'all next time peace
peace